mit ihrem einsatz belegen wir kultur
swisslos wünschte ihnen viel vergnügen
[Musik]
stillstand gibt es nicht
hört auf der veränderlichkeit sowie
dastehen dieses manifest war short
ausgeliehen 1959 über düsseldorf ab
bewegung veränderung kreativ
schöpferisch umgesetzt darin war nie ein
pionier
wir lassen uns vom künstler inspirieren
gehen veränderungen nach und fragen uns
müssen wir uns die sprachen verändern
sie den gesellschaftlichen wandel
anpassen
und wie will sie machtmissbrauch an
schweizer bühnen bekämpfen
[Musik]
wir sind heute in basel beim museum dann
geliebt herzlich willkommen bei
kulturplatz schlägt die pandemie kein
schnippchen und läuft hier auch sonst
alles wie erhofft so heißt es am zweiten
märz türen auf hereinspaziert und das
wäre für war ein fest denn das haus weil
dieses jahr sein 25-jähriges bestehen
während das museum im schotter und von
außen betrachtet in eine art
dornröschenschlaf erstarrter kam im
innern mächtig was in bewegung alle
objekte und maschinen des weltberühmten
kinetik projekten mangele werden neu
präsentiert
roland wetzel als direktor vom museum
tinguely planer das jubiläumsfest für
das september special dell lockt der
stillstand genutzt um freiwilligkeit
viel aber sie ist da alles passiert
einfach die klage könne nutzen um die
ganz heimlich neues richtete das machen
wir alle zwei jahre aber natürlich mit
publikums betrieb und das ist jetzt
eigentlich sehr positiv dass man könne
und in vollen zügen machen alles
verschieben neue aufbauen ohne dass man
rücksicht
es ist so genannt die schiffsreise plant
sie muss ich mir das vorstellen genau
das ist in aller zunge bundesland
hervortraten die schiffsreise wo man
schon paris über amsterdam und den beruf
bis nach basel fahren und unterwegs und
zwölf institutionen besucher und sind
eigentlich alles womit der tanker ist
karriere zu hören so in paris sind erst
die klinik als stehlik aus denen angst
haben mit großer einzel und
gruppenausstellungen bis denn die
rheinland düsseldorf bis nach basel also
großes ereignis für äußerte es wie so
ein ereignis in einer ganz einfachen
zeit zum planen pandemie stichwort im
laufe von tagen sind bewegung
veränderung zerstörung wichtig sie also
hätte vielleicht badespaß seine
künstlerische perspektiven spaß nicht
der hit show sind die kunst ist einfach
immer noch am leben sei und es gab also
die spezielle situation projektor ist
heutzutage und ich glaube hat euro
angebot gemacht wie man sich damit
auseinandersetzen
das geschieht und ich freue mich dass
ich jetzt den knopf ftd de
später werde ich noch schomaker treffen
seit jahrzehnten ein unverzichtbares rat
im tango ließ maschinen werk erhält die
kunst am laufen buchstäblich weltweit
[Applaus]
unhaltbare zustände mit einem beil
schlag zunichte machen das wär's aber
das leben ist manchmal eben doch
komplizierter als dünger ließ komplexe
konstruktionen so auch an schweizer
bühnen die verhältnisse die dort
offenbar teilweise herrschen sind
erschütternd schikane machtmissbrauch
übergriffe und dazu blanes schweigen
ohnmacht doch nun kommt bewegung in die
sache
desolate zustände werden öffentlich
gemacht ganze vier jahre nach me to
cheek deine fetten arsch von einer bühne
ich bin der regisseur und habe hier das
sagen
du bist zu dumm um meine anweisungen
umzusetzen
[Musik]
das sind nur drei von hunderten
anonymisierter aussagen die im rahmen
einer aktuellen umfrage des
schweizerischen bühnenkünstler verbandes
gemacht worden
ihnen soll das dereinst nicht
widerfahren studierenden der zürcher
hochschule der künste
[Musik]
professorin marion bohn engagiert sich
seit jahren für faire arbeitsbedingungen
im kulturbetrieb handlungsbedarf gibt es
vor allem auch in der schweiz
der umgang teils beleidigend respektlos
und immer wieder kommt es zu
machtmissbrauch von regisseuren
direktorin intendanten in der kultur
gehen wir natürlich zurück auf eine sehr
sehr lange tradition in der das
künstlerische nähe immer noch so einen
freibrief hatte dass es diesen diesen
wahnsinn diese nähe diese
distanzlosigkeit in der kunst braucht
wir haben immer von dieser one-man-show
der intendanten gesprochen
die heute auch nicht mehr zeitgemäß ist
derzeit im fokus das zürcher opernhaus
operndirektor michael fichtenholz hat
das haus ende januar verlassen nachdem
abklärungen gegen ihn getätigt wurden
der vorwurf machtmissbrauch zu einer
anzeige kam es nicht
im netz mehren sich die vorwürfe michael
fichtenholz schreibt dass er zu anonymen
äußerungen keine stellung nehmen können
wie verbreitet übergriffe in der
darstellenden kunst hierzulande sind
belegt die bereits erwähnte studie
79 prozent der teilnehmenden erlebten in
den letzten zwei berufsjahren
belästigung verbal aber auch körperlich
meist durch männer nur ein viertel der
bühnen verfügt über einen
verhaltenskodex oder leitfaden
anlaufstellen für betroffene bei weitem
keine norm doch das allein wäre eh nicht
die lösung das ist für server
leutenecker vom schweizerischen
bühnenkünstler verband klar da die
stellen gerade in der schweiz haare sind
die konkurrenz der leistungsdruck und
die existenziellen ängste groß schweigen
mitarbeitende
nur vier prozent der betroffenen haben
sich laut umfrage an ihre vorgesetzten
gewandt es sind ganz besonders menschen
geschädigt die in prekären
abhängigkeitsverhältnissen arbeiten und
ich glaube dieses zusammenspiel von
einer abhängigkeit die mit geld zu tun
hat die mitarbeit unsicherheit zu tun
hat und der möglichkeit von einzelnen
das auszunutzen
das ist das eigentliche problem
es gibt bühnen die sich den auswüchsen
der macht nun aktiv entgegen setzen
das zürcher theater neumarkt oder das
theater gessnerallee etwa die beide auf
eine weibliche dreier intendant setzen
oder das schauspielhaus zürich dass
seine unternehmenskultur gerade öffnet
hin zu mehr transparenz und teilhabe der
mitarbeitenden mitten im reformprozess
das badische staatstheater karlsruhe
intendant peter spuhler muss wegen
seines führungsstils gehen die
belegschaft viel zusammen protestierte
gegen die vergiftete atmosphäre ein
allein herrschende generalintendant soll
es nicht mehr geben
dieses modell das haben wir leidvoll
erfahren kann dazu führen es hängt sehr
stark von den personen ab das zum
machtmissbrauch kommen kann und das
wollen wir wollen wir einfach verändern
indem wir neue strukturen einführen es
soll verhindert werden dass so etwas wie
wir erfahren haben noch mal vorkommt
michael fichtenholz der seinen posten in
zürich räumte verantwortet in karlsruhe
nach wie vor die händel-festspiele dazu
möchte der personalrat derzeit keine
stellung für die prekäre situation der
bühnen künstlerinnen und künstler in der
schweiz macht auch selber leutenecker
die steilen hierarchien in den großen
häusern verantwortlich
jetzt ging institutioneller gemüse oder
dir diese funktionierte die hand so
festgefahrene strukturen das rücklicht
schwierig gesagt müssen sie wenn sie am
er macht das ist das machen das ist nur
an und für sich verständlich habe man es
zu lasten vor der künstlerinnen und
künstler für arbeitnehmende danach ein
muss man das können aussprechen dann
muss man der sache eine bekämpfen
mareike hohem bogen hat in den
niederlanden erwirkt dass nur
kulturinstitutionen die faire practice
kriterien erfüllen subventioniert werden
die schweiz sind meilenweit hinterher
ich bin zurückhaltend weil ich respekt
vor der schweizer gesellschaft aber ich
glaube die schweiz muss einfach
anerkennen dass sie in gewissen themen
ein bisschen nachholbedarf hatte ich
glaube es gibt einen nachholbedarf im
überwinden von patriarchalen strukturen
das wäre hilfreich wenn man das endlich
hinter sich lassen kann
heul nicht halt die klappe
stell dich nicht so dumm an
es reicht die im beitrag erwähnten
abklärungen des opernhaus zürich
betreffend der vorwürfe gegen michael
fichtenholz wurden einvernehmlich
beendet schreibt uns das opernhaus eine
anzeige hat es nicht gegeben es gilt die
unschuldsvermutung
[Musik]
so macht kerstin restaurator und sorgt
für ein gelingen die maschine wie sie
sagen wie viel horror sind jetzt sind
wir dem neues atelier was selber künftig
passieren
da war man den euro bringen warum muss
und das überhaupt machen warum es
wichtig ist die griff zu machen
und jetzt war mal das zeigen was die
sind quasi für die luft
jetzt kommen aber in künftig weitere
gespräche ist es nunmal vor freud trägt
dass ich sicher mit dem reifen aber das
war doch nichts monaco ich gebe relativ
klar auskunft eine ca wenn in den druck
bin und zum schwimmen
das jahr ist ja viel los 25 jahr
jubiläum vor dem fuß dazu gehörten auch
große schiffs und auf dem schiff über
das man sich versetzung das vorstelle
konnte bekannte schwimmen wasser plastik
beruf oder denke ich da brücken und
schleusen auf dem fluss wie ich das
technisch lösen
die haben wir unterschätzt aber ich bin
ganz sicher nie weitere technische
lösung finden bis im juli sind
verschiedene es auch an über 6 ablecken
oder sechs für sankt ansgar in schiffs
buch aber das ist noch nicht spruchreif
ist dir das video hätte mir nur
spezielle zieht wie hebt die ihre
meinung
nur fünf jahre mit ihm zusammen
geschafft ihn erlebt wie hätte recht auf
die pandemie reagiert durch das
stillstand und bewegung
ja das war glaubt spiel ist ehrlicher
mensch wo die
eifrig zahlte sich die immer schneller
dank das geschafft hat und somit also
das war sicher nicht einfach sich
menschen gedanken gemacht was für europa
wo kinetik und bewegung und und und und
das reisen liebt ist das natürlich eine
katastrophe
das hat eigentlich für machine bedeutet
ich meine diesen db5 verschleiß geprägt
hat denen die pause fällig da habe ich
mir gut tut sicher gut aber das ist man
merkt dass das sie brauchen bewegung mit
dem überweg bliebe dass das dass die
nicht formen räume wo lebt wo nicht
wollt sind und darum bleiben sand zu
laufen hat einfach nur für reus und und
um die disco zu schmerzen und dann gern
mal wieder zurück schaue daher ganz
herzlichen dank gerne hört auf der
veränderlichkeit zu widerstehen das hat
er schon und tanga lee uns ans herz
gelegt klingt sinnvoll ist aber nicht
immer einfach zum beispiel beim sprechen
beim sogenannten gender der gender
gerechten oder gender neutralen sprache
ich persönlich habe noch meine inneren
konflikte benutze beim sprechen dass
gender sternchen diese kleine zäsur noch
nicht müssen wir aktiv in unsere sprache
eingreifen um gesellschaftliche
veränderungen zu spiegeln darf sprache
als instrument benutzt werden um
veränderungen anzutreiben
knifflige sache
im universum der sprache wurden neue
himmelskörper gesichtet der gender
sterne ton oder der gender unterstrich
und das binnen i kleine aber feine
veränderungen geschehen
das maskuline keiner wird zum neutralen
niemand aus demselben grund wird jeder
zu alle und am rednerpult stehen nicht
mehr nur männer
neu heisst es gender gericht redepult
kann man mit sprache das denken
verändern
diskriminierungen aus der welt schaffen
ein schlagabtausch zwischen der
journalistin claudia wirtz einer
leidenschaftlichen gegnerin gender
neutraler sprache über diese schon
verschiedentlich publiziert hat und dem
germanisten martin luginbühl einem
verfechter diskriminierung summer
sprache der sich in der gender
linguistik bestens auskennt er sprach
sich auch für frauen und trauer sind mit
irgendwie and sonderfall in der
minderheit sondern sie sieht mehrheit
für den menschen
kaum ein gleichstellungs thema ist zu
kontrovers die einen fürchten die
diktatur der politischen korrektheit die
anderen sehen darin ein instrument für
die soziale inklusion ein ideologisches
minenfeld
hinter der länder sprach steckt
ideologie
das ist die ideologie vor der
gleichstellung sobibor minderheit umgeht
titel will jeder situation vor allem
aber sichtbar machen
das ist wichtig damit dass die jetzige
sprache ganz viel ideologie steckt es
gibt keine ideologiefrei sprachen wir
sagt jeder mann der seit der
verbrüderung also sagen wir das halt
nicht
das prinzip dahinter steckt ist immer
derselbe ist wie sie ist die sogenannte
generische maskulinen
das generische maskulinum bezeichnete
ihn vom geschlecht abstrahierten
gebrauch der männlichen form
man sagt ärzte oder piloten und meint
damit die frauen mit funktioniert und
ich verwende das im text also eigentlich
so wie immer vor zehn fünfzehn york
schrieb ich lerne gern vor schrieben
mehrere bauen
da geht es ganz offensichtlich studie zu
dem generischen maskulinen und die zeigt
dass sie die meisten kontexte meisten
versuche gemacht etwas menschen der welt
aber vor allem am anfang da ist
kantigkeit dem schluss trophy mit welt
gesandt und winkel dieses fantastische
ja gar nicht also solange schulbücher
notorisch vorerst und sekretärinnen ist
es klar wie die konzept noch ein punkt
sind die österreicher
schönheit als knackpunkt denn der
neutrale sprache hört sich häufig nicht
sehr schön an dass es unglaublich
empörend ist unglaublich und elegant
sich unästhetisch und an gymnasien
wirklich anlass freundlichkeit brachte
eleganz - sich diese defizienz das ist
eine frage von radwegen ist es wichtiger
der respektvolle wertschätzende
diskriminierung sprach gebucht
realisieren
oder ist es einfach wichtig ganz knappen
kurz kommunizieren es ist aber auch so
dass form von sprachlichen respekt und
versprach wertschätzung immer mit dem
entsprach liche mehraufwand verbunden
zum gegenüber überzeuge ich respektieren
und wertschätzen
wer es richtig machen will findet
mittlerweile viele anleitungen dazu auch
gesprochene gender sprache hört man
immer häufiger zur ausgesprochenen
freude der befürworterinnen
befürworterinnen diese kleine pause
nennt man glatt ist schlagbar tische aus
einigen timo vorbild charakter und wenn
es so ist dann ist das ein zeichen dass
der wandlitzer relativ fortschrittlich
unter der haut mündliche realisiert wird
dass wir dem es verführt das sprach sich
immer gewandelt hat das ist richtig aber
sprach soll sich mit
planwirtschaftlichen aufgrund von
irgendwelchen er instruktionen vorigen
akademische elite wo ein vorschwebte
das ist kein kann sich kein vorwurf
sieht das akademische sich aber auf ein
phänomen mit https buch thema mehr sagt
fraeulein war franziska aber einige
bezeichnet ist für jugend um früher hat
die frau es ist aber auch unterdessen so
das wetter
studieren die lehren die auszubildende
sind gängige wörter warte die fahrer die
ausgaben im beruf im alltag wo die
geführt hatte sind große diskussionen
geräumt
apropos sprachwandel es gab schon immer
von oben verordnete eingriffe in die
deutsche sprache im siebzehnten
jahrhundert wollte man in einer
nationalistischen aufwallung fremdwörter
ein deutschen der schriftsteller philipp
von zesen erfand neue wörter aus distanz
wurde etwa abstand aus moment der
augenblick aus dem auto der verfasser so
wie man sich damals an diesen neuen
wörter gewöhnt hat werden wir uns
vielleicht dereinst an gender neutrale
formulierung gewöhnen die frage ob er
das als ideologische bevormundung
empfinden oder als zeichen des sozialen
wandels muss jeder und jede für sich
beantworten
[Musik]
so dann wird wer die sache jetzt auch
noch kaputt die diese sendung geht es ja
um große und kleine veränderungen in den
geschichten des weltweit erfolgreichen
schriftstellers benedix welt ist die
veränderung weist eine einschneidende so
auch in seinem neuen roman heartland
rund um sex liebe verlust und das
erwachsenwerden
[Musik]
benedict wells schreibt bücher die
beglücken obwohl sie immer auch traurig
sind
[Musik]
ist auch einfach verrückt mit einer
bestseller erste auflage von 120.000
exemplaren liegt nun sein neuestes werk
hart lernt vor
hier in der deutschen auslieferungs
halle signiert er trotz corona bücher
für seine fans wie wirkt sich die
pandemie auf sein schaffen aus schade
dass das buch durchschnitt oft
ungeordneten gemittelt das tut mir das
hat mir schon fürs schreiben und gegen
ein studium entscheidet sich welz nach
dem abitur radikal
er hält sich mit gelegenheitsjobs über
wasser und schreibt mit 19 seinen ersten
roman auf den niemand gewartet hat
bestimmte situationen und das ist quasi
libysche flucht nach vorn
quasi ich behandelt werde weglaufen oder
der sprachlosigkeit sondern beruf
zurückgegangen
man wähle turbo um die woods findet und
ich kann natürlich philippe zweifel
am anfang bin ich da und abgelehnt wurde
jahrelang doch dann ein anruf des
zürcher diogenes verlags der welt leben
auf den kopf stellt diogenes bringt
seinen roman becks letzter sommer heraus
da ist wels gerade 24 jahre alt der
roman erhält lob von kritik und publikum
und wird mit christian ulmen prominent
verfängt wer spielt einen lehrer der
lieber rockstar wäre und sich jetzt als
songwriter versucht mit seinem vierten
roman vom ende der einsamkeit kommt 2016
der große durchbruch
eine halbe million verkaufte bücher
es ist die geschichte von drei
geschwistern deren eltern ums leben
kommen es geht um verlust ums
erwachsenwerden
es ist immer interessant ist wenn du
über die branche und über die
entwicklung von menschen in seinem
neuesten buch hat land erfährt der
teenager sam fundamentale veränderungen
es geht um freundschaft liebe sex und
tod
schon der erste satz ein paukenschlag
der den sound vorgibt
in diesem sommer verliebte ich mich und
meine mutter starb
einen sommer lang jobbt außenseiters m
im kino schwärmt für die selbstsichere
kirstie schreibt songs und sorgt sich um
seine todkranke mutter kämpft mit dem
erwachsenwerden pubertät ein thema das
den mittlerweile 36-jährigen wels
umtreibt und für eine stärkere anderes
und deutsch natürlich die pubertät oder
das coming of age ist natürlich die
ultimative entwickelt und für mich ich
schaue mir wichtig sie natürlich die
einsamkeit die dann wenn du dich
verändert ist der bischof vor dem moment
sehr einsam
die einsamkeit des heranwachsenden sah
seine angst das leben ohne seine mutter
nicht zu bewältigen die hochgefühle wenn
er mit der umschwärmten küste zusammen
ist welt schreibt als wäre man als leser
mitten drin
ich dachte er den herrlichen sommer der
vor mir lag dass nun endlich alles
anfangen würde und stadt unser gartentor
zu benutzen hüpfte ich über den zaun
beschwingt schlief ich ein und dann
warte ich nur wenig später mit schwindel
und herzrasen aus einem albtraum auf
die geschichte zieht den leser mal in
die eine mal in die andere richtung
auch wells protagonisten sind emotional
hin und hergerissen erfinden dafür den
begriff frank rühli glück rechtzeitig
schoss pc-sparte mehr stimmen als gefühl
dafür dass das leben endlich ist dadurch
aus dass das gehörte der gefühl für die
jugend so vermisse wenn du es nur herr
über seine eigene jugend und familie
marx benedict wells der eine schweizer
mutter hat nicht sprechen
doch seit einiger zeit lebt er nach
stationen in berlin und barcelona in
zürich ich habe endlich wird das dass
die schweizer heimat für zu früh und mit
verlagen die schweiz habe warnt die
stiftung mit spitzen nationalmannschaft
mit viel liebe turniere oder so rappaz
klar ich wollte mir umgeht
im herbst will er auf jeden fall auch in
seiner neuen heimat auf lesetour gehen
was danach kommt weiß er noch nicht
gerade eben habe er das gefühl es sei
jetzt alles geschrieben was raus musste
das wollen wir leser aber mal nicht
hoffen
[Musik]
benedict wells ist kommenden sonntag
auch zu gast in 52 beste bücher um 11
uhr auf radio sf2 kultur
[Musik]
kunst ist unsinn und wie alles nicht
sinnlos auch dieses zitat von jean
tinguely nehme ich heute gerne mit bevor
es hier auf sf1 gleich weitergeht mit
der serie fossey werben möchte ich noch
auf den nächsten kulturplatz hinweisen
da beschäftigen wir uns damit dass immer
mehr junge menschen eine geschlechts
angleichung anstreben
wann ist man als genug für diesen
schritt
das also nächsten mittwoch für heute
bedanke ich mich im namen der ganzen
redaktion fürs dabeisein sagen tschüss
und immer schön in bewegung bleiben
[Musik]
mit ihrem einsatz bewegen wir kultur
swisslos